what if we make a function that does all
of that work upfront and then we just
let the van and the cop class do a tiny
bit of customization for whatever's left
to make them different from regular cars
we would call this new function we're
building a superclass that term includes
the word class because this function
will be creating a lot of similar
objects and it includes the word super
because these other classes will use the
output from this superclass as their
starting point let's name the function
car since it's going to be creating
objects that have the generic moving
behavior and then van and cop will be
even more specific versions of it which
parts of van and cop do you think could
be moved up into the body of the car
constructor function